hello and welcome to this video playing
much Leo with black think okay I thought
you place them thought you played the
Italian okay anyway get a scotch gambit
in transpose into an Italian game yeah
this this particular line recently has
gained some popularity white is really
trying four lots and four alternatives
to them to the Berlin and they try a lot
in the in the Italian game okay um f 6
cm or let's do it
okay let's keep it simple Wow so where
are you canceling after Bishop a6 know
where is the answer probably I mean also
sorry and long you're probably long
castles Bishop g4 is also an interesting
move yeah why not putting some pressure
on the noid quince is six I can take him
it's got queen e 6th oh ok it shouldn't
be bad okay take sir hmm
Bishop f3 he wants to cheat one g7
you should definitely takes on g7 hmm
I don't have a good reply to that the
bad thing is say yes 95 now context 95
is a really annoying new for all of the
Sun putting pressure on c6
huh that's not good I don't want to take
with the pawn that looks totally wrong
yeah very strange
very strange how did I get to that the
problem is my bishop on b6 is not doing
anything absolutely nothing they can
take c68 will this position is just bad
it is just bad
a very very limited counter play em
unfortunately
okay threatening this he will take you
five but I just want to mix it up
somehow hey threatens night of seven
months so I cannot even go to eight as I
intended namely
he still could've played them over okay
very nice blackening resigned and no
okay um so yeah he just played it nicely
I think and this I couldn't really I
couldn't refute it this seems to be bad
then here due to taking on f6 amazing
yeah it's just not good i cannot take on
f3 I have no good move I mean that I was
clearly it was after Queen have six but
yeah maybe I should have done that I
mean it is better than the game it still
looks bad but it's better than the game
yeah not bad actually after 95 I'm just
in an absolutely terrible shape yeah
well f6 is certainly normal and cream be
three yeah I have to have to improve
here I just have to improve the position
cannot be bad for black that would be
very strange because I just played the
absolute normal main line oh yeah the
engine wants to play a five yeah not
very happy with this Queenie 8 it's
awesome that can be considered but you
always gets this here there are tricks
like c5 but
now that it's also not great hmm yeah
this is the computers move it's not
really clear what this move is doing
well okay if he cancels i have bishop
360 Bishop g4 now this is this is
possible of course something like this
now doesn't really hurt in the game um
he hadn't cancelled which is a big
difference I mean here's a pure black is
fine so in five and two yeah the
computer wants to take here and then
Bishop g4 with the quality it's very
very tough here yeah and you have to
cheat with the pawn and now I'm just
busted yeah I don't know maybe I could
have done something more testing but the
position is just terrible you're
essentially you play against this
fantastic a five-night and this Bishop
won't be six is dead I mean really dad
they are care this was easy an output
yeah I played it well what can you do
okay thanks for watching